اهلا بكم الى موجزه لاهم الانباء قالت
الاداره العسكريه
فيسك ان ثلاثه اشخاص قتلوا اصيب 25 في قصف
روسيا استهدف احد المباني في مدينه
كريفيري جنوب شرقيه اوكرانيا واضافت
الاداره العسكريه ان سبعه اشخاص لا يزالون
عالقين تحت الانقاض وان الجهود مستمره
لانقاذهم وقد وصف الرئيس الاوكراني
القصف بالارهابي محملا روسيا المسؤوليه عن
كل صاروخ اطلقته اعتزمنا الهجوم مع اعلان
هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه اسقاط عشره
صواريخ مجنحه استهدفت مدنا اوكرانيه عده
الليله الماضيه
في غضون ذلك افاد حكيم مقاطعه
الروسيه باستمرار القصف الاوكراني منذ
صباح اليوم لمنطقتين في المقاطعه الحدوديه
من جهاته قال الرئيس الاوكراني ان القوات
بلاده تتقدم في الهجوم المضاد رغم ضراوه
المعارك مشيرا الى ان خسائر العدو تتطابق
مع الخطط الاوكرانيه
افاد مراسل الجزيره في السودان باستخدام
اسلحه ثقيله في اشتباكات بين قوه الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع قرب المنطقه الصناعيه
وحيي ارميله والحله الجديده غرب الخرطوم
كما سمع دوي انفجارات في ام درمان ومدن
الخرطوم الثلاثه
في قمه ايجاد التي عقدت في جيبوتي قال
الرئيس الكيني ان الايجاده توصلت الى
مبادره لحل الازمه في السودان تشمل وقفا
لاطلاق النار وفتحه ممرات امنه واداره
حوار بين قوى مدنيه
من جانبه قال مالك عجاره نائب رئيس مجلس
السياده السودانيه للجزيره ان هيئه
الايجاد اقترحت لقاء بين البرهان وحميتي
خلال اسبوعين ولم يحدد عجار لم يحدد مكان
اللقاء
اعلنت القياده الوسطى للقوات الامريكيه
اصابه 22 فردا عسكريا في حادثه تعرضت لها
مروحيه في شمال شرق سوريا يوم الاحد
الماضي واضافت القياده ان الجنود المصابين
يخضعون للعلاج وقالت ان تحقيق يتواصل
لمعرفه سبب الحادث مشيره الى انه لم يتم
رصد اطلاق نيران معاديه
وصل الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
الى ولايه فلوريدا عشيه مثوله امام
المحكمه بعد توجيه 37 تهمه فيدراليه له
على خلفيه حيازه وثائق سريه بعد مغادرته
البيت الابيض وقد تجمع عدد من مناصري
ترامب خارج منتجع دورال في ميامي مرددينه
تافات تدفع ببراءه ترامب وتدعو لقول ما
يصفونه بالحقيقه كما دعوا الى توجيه نفس
التهم للرئيس الحالي جو بايدن
نقل موقع واكسوس على مسؤولين اسرائيليين
وامريكا ان الحكومه الاسرائيليه ابلغت
اداره بايدن انها تعتزم الاعلانات هذا
الشهر عن بناء وتخطيط الاف الوحدات
السكنيه الجديده في المستوطنات بالضفه
الغربيه المحتله واشار الموقع الى ان
اداره بايدن تضغط على الحكومه الاسرائيليه
لثنيها عن هذه الخطوه
الجانبه طالب رئيس الوزراء الفلسطيني بضغط
دولي حقيقي لمنع تقسيم الضفه الغربيه عبر
مخطط
e1 الاستيطاني
ختم هذا الموجه شكرا لكم والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]